My guest tonight is a hilarious comedian
and actress who hosts the
Netflix series Nailed It,
as well as five podcasts.
Good god, five!
Including Why Don't You Date Me.
Her new book is called
#VERYFAT #VERYBRAVE.
Please welcome our good
friend Nicole Byer.
Nicole, we will get to the
book in just a few minutes,
but first of all, tell
me, you look gorgeous.
You look beautiful.
Thank you, Conan.
Yes, I love the regal.
And how are you doing these days?
You know, honestly I
think most Black people
have had a rough couple of weeks.
It's been not fun, but also nice to see
so many people feel emboldened
to be in the streets with us,
to be protesting with us.
That feels good, but
you know it just sucks
that another Black man was
killed that was unarmed,
and woman!
Breonna Taylor, you know.
It's (beep) up.
Yeah, yeah.
That's a good summation.
(laughter)
Not quite as eloquent
as some of the speeches
I have heard, but probably
the most to the point.
Oh yeah.
Would you say that, and I don't want
to lead you with this question,
but is the reaction making you
more hopeful, less hopeful?
Where do you think you are, personally?
Um, I think the reaction makes me
incredibly hopeful because I feel
like too many people were radicalized
who understand that we have
been going through this shit
for so long, 450 years,
like the longest time!
We got brought over, we
weren't treated very nicely
because slavery was bad.
And then after slavery,
Jim Crow, that was awful.
Like, I still have aunts
who are still alive
who remember segregation.
Like, that's insane to me.
So I think a lot of white
people's eyes were opened
and that, to me, makes me so excited.
Like, my roommate is a very white man.
Oh, he's so white.
And he was going to protests with me,
and was explaining to his mom
that police brutality is a
real thing and it's awful.
And then he went to a protest by himself,
and then I came home and he was humming
a chant from the protest
and frying chicken,
and I was like, did this go
fully in the other direction?
What is going on?
But it's so nice.
You think maybe he went too far,
or do you think it was still okay?
Oh, it was chicken nuggets.
It wasn't like deep fried chicken,
so I was like it's not
super all the way there.
He's like just teetering
around, but I appreciate it.
I appreciate that he's
going to protests alone.
I appreciate that my white friends
for the most part have
not been bothering me.
I got good white people in my life
who are posting for each
other's shit they should read.
Nobody's going, Nicole,
what should I read.
What should I be doing?
Like, they've been doing the work.
My one friend Elinor, she sends me stuff.
She'll be like, this protest is happening.
And I'm like, this is an
active ally, not a good ally.
Because we need active allies.
You can be as good as you
want inside your house,
but that's not going to
do anything for anybody.
Yeah, it's one of the things
that I think about is,
and I've been talking to
a lot of different people
in the last two weeks
who have been telling me
over and over again that Black people
are tired of explaining their situation.
Oh yeah!
That it's exhausting and their saying
you go, you white people go out,
do your homework, you do the work,
and get back to us or
whatever you gotta do,
but please stop asking us to explain
over and over and over again
as if this is a new phenomenon.
Yeah, it's not new.
It's been around since everybody
on this planet was born.
Also, like Google.com.
(laughing)
It's filled with so much information.
And yeah, Black people,
we've been talking about it.
Like, in my stand up shows
I spend about 10 minutes
talking about racial injustices
and being racially profiled.
I mean, it is comedy and it is funny,
and every now and again
at a meet and greet
I'll have someone be like,
did that really happen to you.
And I was like, why
would I lie about that?
It's a horrific experience
that I found the humor in,
because that's what Black
people have been doing
for the longest time.
Awful shit happens to us
and then we turn it around
and we make it fun and funny
because how else would we survive.
Slaves sang songs because
they had to find joy,
even though they were living
this horrible existence.
Right, right.
It is interesting that people think,
obviously the last two
weeks has been filled.
It started with this horrific image
of George Floyd's killing
and we went from there,
but it is amazing to think
that comedians like yourself
are able to walk this sort of knife edge
of talking about it, getting
your feelings out about it,
but also miraculously somehow
making it very funny at times
that might speak to people who
might not otherwise hear you.
It's interesting, it's
amazing what comedy can do.
Yeah, like Chris Rock.
This has been floating around,
I think it was in his last special,
but he was like, cops, a few bad apples,
I'm butchering this man's joke,
but it essentially was just like,
what if American Airlines was
like we got a few bad apples.
A couple of them like
to crash into mountains.
And it's like, yeah, why do we keep saying
that a few bad apples is
okay in a police department?
That's no!
I had one bad apple in
a bowl, and guess what?
The rest of the apples tasted like shit.
So I think that's what's happening.
Right, right.
You've talked about how racial inequality
can manifest itself in healthcare,
which is something
probably a lot of people
aren't fully aware of.
They're aware of, we hear about
the more overt, blatant forms
of racial inequality, but healthcare.
And you've experienced that yourself.
Oh yeah.
I fully flew off a motorcycle in December.
I was taking my road test and I failed it
in maybe the most spectacular way,
and I was limping and I had
this huge gash in my leg.
And I went to urgent care
and they took an X ray,
and they were like here are some crutches
and here's a great
recommendation of an ice pack.
And I was like, that's it?
And they were like, we don't
think you need any more.
And then like two weeks later
I was in Buffalo, New York
with one of my dear friends, Kristy,
and she had a sinus infection
so she went to urgent care
and then they gave her
like Tylenol codeine,
a Z pack and all this shit.
And I was like, wait what?
And then I started doing literally
the slightest amount of research.
I went to my friend
Google.com and googled this,
and apparently it stems from slavery times
where people were like Black people
heal faster, they're stronger,
they don't experience pain,
and it was to make
white people feel better
about trading human beings
and whipping human beings
and Black women, specifically,
get the least amount of care.
We die sometimes in awful ways.
Like there was a woman,
she was a teacher in Brooklyn, I believe.
She went to the hospital.
She said she had shortness of breath,
she wasn't feeling good.
She thought she had COVID-19.
They sent her home.
She called an ambulance to her house.
They said she was fine.
And then she made her way to the hospital,
was on a ventilator for like two weeks,
and then died because nobody believed her.
And they think that Black people
are like seeking
narcotics or whatever, but
I can't believe you took
the Hippocratic Oath
and you can't look someone in the eye
and just try to help them.
Mm-hm.
You're saying that
there's literally a sense
that a white physician might have
that this Black person doesn't not feel
the amount of pain that we feel,
so I don't need to give them, prescribe
the really good Tylenol
because they're not feeling
what my white patient is feeling.
Correct.
Or they just don't believe us.
Maybe he thought I was lying
about being on a motorcycle,
but no, I'm trying real hard.
2020, I'm gonna be a bad ass.
But it's been hard.
Yeah, yeah.
Are you really riding a
motorcycle these days?
Yes!
I bought a motorcycle, but I truly
only take it around my cul-de-sac,
because I was like, if I fall off again
and I actually have to
go to a real hospital,
COVID-19, I don't want that!
Right, well wear the
helmet for god's sake,
even if you're going 20 yards.
Wear the helmet and wear the
good jackets with the armor.
Mm-hmm, and I have armored pants now.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
None of this riding around in Daisy Dukes.
We'll talk about that later.
(laughing)
I wanted to congratulate you
because Nailed It, you were nominated
Critics Choice Award for female star.
That's really exciting.
It is exciting because I am a star
and I'm so glad that
people are taking notice!
No, I'm kidding.
It's nice.
But you're not kidding.
People love the show.
You're so funny on the show
and it's connected you
to this whole audience.
I mean, kids!
I mean, adults love the show, as well,
but kids go crazy for your show.
They love you, which is nice.
You're speaking directly
to all these young people.
That's fantastic.
Thanks!
I mean, I don't like kids.
I just, there's something about them.
(laughter)
They got too many questions.
They're sticky.
A bunch of kids have been
drawing pictures of me
and their parents are
posting it on Twitter,
and I'm like, this is bad!
(laughter)
Why are you sending this to me?
Keep this, I don't want this!
We're already having a bad week.
I don't want to look at
your kid's ugly drawing.
They're adorable.
You've got this great
critically-acclaimed show.
People love it, it's a hit.
It's got a huge kid fan base,
and you're going after kids, okay.
(laughter)
Only you would do that.
I want to talk about your book.
Congratulations.
#VERYFAT #VERYBRAVE and it is filled
with amazing photographs.
Thank you.
Really fantastic photographs.
Your photographer, your
poses are incredible.
Conan, thank you.
I love, there's a picture in
here I ant find it right now
of you in front of an In-N-Out.
Oh yeah.
I love this picture.
[Nicole] Thank you!
Just, I mean, we've all been there.
(laughter)
I've been in front of an In-N-Out
in my leopard skin bikini
and this is really a great.
What is your message?
What is your message
with #VERYFAT #VERYBRAVE,
because the photographs
alone are terrific,
but I know that you're trying
to accomplish a little more here.
A little bit.
My friend Kim Newmoney took the pictures
and my friend Allison Rich was like,
you should do a coffee table book.
And I was like, okay.
And then as I was writing it,
I was like, it's so dumb that people call
fat women brave for wearing bikinis.
So I was like, why don't I just make fun
of that whole weird phenomenon.
But I hope people read the book.
I mean, it's a quick read.
Truly you can read it
in like an hour or two,
but I hope people finish it
and then go, why did I ever give a shit
about what people think about me?
Why did I ever care?
If someone stares at me,
that means my body
disrupted their life enough
that they needed to stop what
they were doing to look at me,
that means my body is powerful.
Also, every body is
beautiful in its own way.
And every body is different.
And the world is all right
like really, really hard,
so why would you spend it hating
what you see in the mirror?
That's like an extra layer of misery.
Have you, you've always been,
and I think it's a
remarkable quality you have,
but you're just always so
comfortable with yourself.
And I'm curious is that
who you've always been,
or did you have to get to that place?
I've always been pretty
comfortable with myself.
My mom used to call me
Tina because I would scream
a lot like Tina Turner and
I listed to Tina Turner
and scream along to that.
And I've always kinda marched
to my own little drumbeat.
I don't know.
It's more fun to just
figure out who you are
and just be that.
Spending time trying to be somebody else
seems so exhausting and also crazy.
Yeah, yeah.
I grew up not liking
anything about myself.
Well, why?
Conan, you're tall!
That's luxurious.
You have red hair.
How exotic!
You have all your teeth.
What a treat!
(laughter)
Wait, okay, so you had three qualities
you liked about me and one of them
was I have all my teeth.
(laughter)
That did nothing to make me feel better.
I want to ask you about,
you're on a mission
to get people to embrace spandex.
Let's talk about that.
Why spandex?
Because spandex is your friend.
Like, if you hold something up
and you're like I don't
know if this is gonna fit,
pull it!
If it has spandex, it probably does fit!
Also, if it's too tight, who cares!
People already know you're fat.
If you wear bigger clothes people will go
look at that fatty.
If you wear tighter clothes people will go
What's the difference?
(laughter)
Who cares!
Just wear what you want.
So you think everyone
should be wearing spandex?
Yes, Conan.
I would like you to
wear some spandex, okay?
No, it's not gonna be good,
it's not gonna be good.
Come on, Conan, put on some spandex!
Uh, okay.
Nicole, your logic is just too powerful.
I say no, and you say yes,
and so I'm going to do it.
Not happy with my body
and spandex is gonna
bum a lot of people out.
But it might make three people happy.
That's more than no people.
(laughter)
You know what it would
do, it would get laughs,
which in our profession.
That's gold.
We love laughs because we're
sad people on the inside.
I don't think you are.
I don't think you're a sad person.
No I'm not, I'm very happy.
You have to check out this book.
It's a great read and also
the pictures are fantastic.
It's by Nicole.
It's #VERYFAT #VERYBRAVE
and a terrific book.
Also, Nicole, you have a list
of Black-owned bookstores, is that right,
that we want to put up?
Yeah, because it might be
hard after the pandemic
for Black-owned businesses to come back,
especially since it's harder for us
to get loans and whatnot.
So now is the time to support.
I also have a list of
Black-owned restaurants,
but I think it's only
in LA, in my bio, too.
Okay, all right.
Well, like I say, one of the things
that I've been picking up
just in the last two weeks
of conversations is it's not about
good, I did three things
and now racism is gone.
We all know that's not gonna happen.
It's about living life
being a little more present,
being a little more
aware and doing the work
every day in small ways.
Sometimes big ways, sometimes small ways
and supporting Black-owned
businesses is huge.
It's a huge thing.
If you find a Black-owned
coffee shop in your neighborhood
go there instead of Starbucks.
It's not that hard.
It's just minor adjustments
that you can make in your life
that will deeply impact
someone else's life
because that Black-owned business
can start generational
wealth to give to their kids,
which is a beautiful thing.
Yeah, they're also not gonna be
selling you a Kenny G CD there.
No, you might get
something more interesting.
But I gotta say, Kenny G,
he got good hair, right?
He got the long hair with the saxophone?
Long hair, yeah, yeah.
And he's fine.
I've got no beef with
him, I'm just saying.
Do you, Conan, do you
have beef with Kenny G?
Yes I do, he took my woman!
Oh no!
I made that up, but it could happen.
My wife could run off with
Kenny G, it could happen.
I don't think so.
It is so nice to see you.
Wait, is that Abraham Lincoln behind you?
This, I've had an Abraham
Lincoln up here forever.
Yeah, it's the last
photograph ever taken of him.
It's a rare outdoor
photograph of Abraham Lincoln.
Where he don't have no body.
What's that?
He doesn't have a body.
He had a body, they just didn't have
an iPhone back then
that caught everything.
So whatever, you know.
I've got this place.
Conan, how are you?
Has anyone asked how you're doing?
No, it hasn't really occurred to anybody
to ask me how I'm doing.
How are you, Conan?
(laughter)
Well, I think the last two weeks
has been hardest on me.
(laughter)
And I'm shocked you're the
first person to notice it!
You're the first person to reach out,
but that's how egotistical I am.
I somehow thought Black Lives
Matter was all about me.
I got confused, that's what an idiot I am.
And you're an ally who's learning.
Well, we all need to learn faster and more
and more and faster.
But you know, I'm doing great.
And you know what, I'm very lucky because
I'm very fortunate that I'm able
to keep doing this thing that I do
during this time of
COVID and all this unrest
and mostly because it gives
me a lot of hope and joy.
Like talking to you
today, this is not a job.
Touching base with you
just makes me happy.
You just bring me a lot of joy
every time you come on the show.
You're so naturally funny
and you're such a beautiful spirit
that seeing you today makes me happy.
It just really makes me happy.
Conan, thank you!
You're saving me right now,
which is really what it's all about.
I love how this was a nice compliment
that went right back to Conan.
I'm a genius at that.
(laughter)
Let me hold this up again because I want
to make sure people check it out.
#VERYFAT #VERYBRAVE.
Get this book.
And Nicole, thank you
so much for being here
and be well and I can't
wait to see you in person.
Samesies!
Conan, I adore you.
What's that mean, Conan?
You and I have a chemistry.
What does that mean?
It just means it's undeniable.
You've been around me and I get around you
and you know what I'm saying.
Yeah, I can't wait to
see you again, Conan.
(laughter)
Truly, you're delightful.
Take care, I love you,
and I'll see you soon.
Bye, Conan!